metaphysical milkshake hello it's me
rain wilson i'm one of the hosts i am
the other host reza aslan hi rain
hi reza aslan how are you doing i'm
doing
as well as one could be expected to be
doing considering the world that we live
in right now the imminent collapse
of the human global order you mean yep
yep yeah
every time you open the news it's like
some new way
the world is gonna die now it's some new
strain of coronavirus right today was a
an article in the new york times that
apparently a majority of americans
not so fond of democracy
not uh yep thinking that you know
democracy is pretty much dead in america
totalitarianism totalitarianism is right
around the corner i also heard about uh
diseases that might come up from the
rapidly thawing permafrost in siberia oh
that'd be interesting oh good i'm i'm
looking forward uh to to prehistoric
versions of covid that that's gonna be
fun welcome to metaphysical milkshake
the show where we go deep we get weird
and we search for the meaning of life
along the way presented by cast media
and soul pancake
[Music]
this gets depressing so quickly um let's
lighten it up a little bit the end of
the world um
there's so many movies there's mad max
there's hunger games there's so many
kind of apocalyptic
post-apocalyptic films
what do you what do you think what would
be the coolest way
for the world to end the coolest way
what kind of what movie would you want
to watch
like some kind of emp
disaster like an electromagnetic pulse
like some kind of pulse maybe it's from
outer space maybe it's a it's a local
thing and like all electronics goes away
like just suddenly everything all
electronics done
reza reza reza yeah that means no more
podcasts a and b
you wouldn't be able to check your
twitter feed oh my god that is the end
of the world that uh yeah that
but what do you like what do you like
about that though what is what's
exciting to you about that do you like
the idea of being plunged into some kind
of stone age with no power grid wouldn't
they just get the power grid up and
running and would just take a couple
months
i don't know i think i think that would
the disruption would be so extreme
because we're all so
so you know
connected connected and we rely we're so
reliant on
on you know everything but it's like if
it all went away like the cloud
disappeared everything was gone start
from scratch my book is on the cloud i
can't have the cloud you better print
that [ __ ] up right away oh my god and
yeah and we are we're kind of stoned i
look if i'm gonna pick the end that
seems like
you know
better than most i got a better one tell
me
body snatchers
the
invasion of the body snatchers the 1978
version
donald sutherland is so i watched it
with my son recently it still holds up
it really really in the end what about
the end oh my
god plant pod alien plant pod people
replacing humans
and then everyone is just emotionless
and united um
is
it's chilling but fighting the plant pod
people but you can't fall asleep so
you've got this this you know obstacle
this internal obstacle that you want to
sleep
that's really exciting to me
that would be uh that would be fun i'd
love to be part of the resistance
movement
i don't think i don't think our guest uh
did an episode
on pod people
not
he did do an episode on pretty much
every other way that the world can end
we're talking of course about bill nye
the science guy you know him you love
him honestly who doesn't like bill nye i
mean what what [ __ ] out there fox
news doesn't like bill nye [ __ ]
exactly uh he's got a new show this is
actually a really good idea for a show i
really hope it's successful but the show
is called the end is nigh
which premieres august 25th on peacock
and uh essentially the show is just like
he he explores
uh in a very dramatic way with a lot of
uh special effects uh different ways in
which the world can come to an end so
really really fun show yeah he's one of
my personal heroes we have northwest
roots we're going to get into that bill
nye is a mechanical engineer he worked
at boeing he's a science communicator
he's a television presenter uh he's best
known as the host of the science
television show bill nye the science guy
which ran for six years the netflix show
bill nye saves the world and for his
many many many many appearances in
popular media as a science educator he
attended cornell and studied at the
sibley school of mechanical and
aerospace engineering and
two fun facts he holds three us patents
one for ballet point shoes
one for an educational magnifying glass
created by filling a clear plastic bag
with water and one for a device for
training an athlete to throw
a ball that one i need proof for that i
need to i need to google that yields a
design patent for a digital abacus
and
funnest of all fun facts as of 2019 is
bow tie collection numbered roughly 500.
and one last fun fact uh turns out he
just got married this past may so
congratulations to bill and mrs science
guy
[Laughter]
please welcome to the show bill dye
bill nye the science guy welcome to
metaphysical milkshake it's so good to
be here just to be clear um can we call
you bill or should we call you mr the
science guy
i'd go with bill no okay all right now
i've got i'll be i'll i'll tell you i
have thought about changing my name
to e-bill
because we get so many of those
uh it would just be easier for people
i thought i haven't done it but we know
we all get bills in the mail but i've
thought about going with it i like that
i like that e-bill so you know we were
talking about your new show a little bit
at the opening um uh the end is nigh
great name by the way and also just a
kind of a great idea for a show to be
honest with you so well thank you uh you
know seth macfarlane who's one of the
executive producers
points out that
conservative media scare people they
scare people that's why you watch it
it's scary
and when
times are wonderful and happy
what was that guy's name walt whitman
and all is right with the world
people watch romantic comedies and
comedies and have fun
when times are more uncertain
people watch disaster movies like right
you'd think you'd think let me awake let
me get away from this but that's not
human nature you you did you dip deeper
into it and so
the end is nigh is six episodes and each
one of them is a disaster that's right
each one is a different disaster yeah so
you're trying to tap into the zeitgeist
with this yeah it's all about the
zeitgeist what's what is the most
serious problem facing humankind
it's not a trick question climate change
yeah climate change so the first episode
is about
catastrophes associated with climate
change based on real
climate computer models science yeah
science yeah and so we but note well
yeah note well we never explicitly use
the phrase climate change
you know that's funny that's true
i did notice that it was always like
extreme weather or like
yeah that's how you refer to it as
extreme weather why why why is that
well you don't need it is the argument
is
that when you have all this extra heat
energy in the ocean
and then the atmosphere is also warmer
uh then you have the
very likely the strong likelihood of big
storms
and you know katrina the famous or
infamous rather uh hurricane
was a category five
five
but category six hurricanes happen
but so far only on the open ocean
but what if one of those came ashore
what makes a category five versus six
what is it
you know you guys
it's arbitrary but it's arbitrary based
on science you know people have studied
wind speeds it's wind speed
but then this really cool scale was
developed for hurricane measuring based
on
based on the destruction of structures
the de-structure of structures oh wow
and so it turns out to be very
uh very good you can people who civil
engineers who know how strong buildings
are can look at damage done by
hurricanes and infer the wind speed with
great accuracy
not that that's what you want to do all
day but that's what some people do is it
the same group that names the hurricanes
that's a good question that's a good
question the answer is sort of i think
they all know each other they all hang
out together but the official people or
the used to be the weather service now
it's national oceanic and atmospheric
administration
but there's international agreements on
that also you know because hurricanes we
call them hurricanes in the northern
hemisphere and cyclones in the southern
hemisphere so was this was the idea for
the show yours i mean was this something
that you had been cooking up
well it was i'd say it was bran and
braga and me now if you want to say it
was all bran and i'll go along with that
but we uh we met in his backyard
for a couple months during you know when
kovid was serious biz it means still
serious but when people really worry
about dying
we'd meet in his open backyard in los
angeles with bulletin boards and stuff
and
i claim there are a couple moments of
insight listen the show is so
entertaining it's funny it's very
visually it's incredible what you guys
did on a limited budget with the visuals
yeah they're insane we're freaking
geniuses yes you know thank you
it really is it's like just a series of
fantastic mini disaster movies but other
than the fact that we live in perilous
times and people want to watch disasters
what do you hope that people will take
from the show what what is your what is
your goal in you know digging into the
science of catastrophe the goal
is to dare i say it
change the world
wow
yeah
how would it change the world we get
people thinking about
what you could do
to make disasters less disastrous
the journey you could embark on to
making us all more prepared for
disasters
and writ large this takes trusting the
science
so for those who don't know bill uh got
his start in seattle on a local comedy
show
uh which was a talk show comedy show
variety show like an improv kind of uh
it was a
little bit it had all aspects it had a
desk like it was a talk show there were
guests on the talk show there were
science experiments in the lab people
would bring in animals just like on the
tonight show and then it would go remote
for pre-recorded comedy sketches that
you'd shoot through the week uh joel
mchale was a part of it apparently
later on
yeah later on he's so much younger than
i am it was the pride of seattle and as
a as a dorky seattleite born and raised
in the u district went to shortcrest
high school university of washington
high school on the shoreline
he knows about germany i'm jim
but everybody almost live this comedy
show was on the nbc affiliate king tv
seattle is in king county
and uh it was on at 11 30 on saturday
nights displacing on the nbc affiliate
saturday night live that's a half hour
saturday night live in seattle during
our heyday would start at midnight
that's right and the ratings for almost
live were generally a little better
than saturday night live now to be sure
this was during saturday night lives not
the best years
right but never but we claimed we were
pretty good
we were pretty good
it was it was amazing and and i i
understand in doing a little bit of
research that you kind of started doing
your particular brand of comedy science
presentation based on a kick-ass
killer steve martin impression can you
give us a taste
well
okay everybody
let us just let's review
[Laughter]
the year
1978
steve martin's first two albums were
hugely influential i claim that steve
martin's first two albums
were so influential that every city in
the u.s and english-speaking canada had
one or two comedy clubs like in a
weekend
like from 19 by by 1980
even the 13th television market seattle
had two comedy clubs
and so what happened was
in 1978 steve martin was so successful
that they warner brothers records
sponsored a steve martin look-alike
contest
and the word look-alike would include
performing
in steve martin
stage performer as a comedian fashion
and so my my claim
i don't know if you're of a certain i
don't know if you're of a certain age
where you remember the nightclub called
montana's
in seattle it's i can't go there now
because it burned down
no fault of mine
but uh the comedy competition for
seattle was held there and i won i mean
i claim it was a venn diagram
of the circles i was bill nye not bill
nye that's my claim all right so after
that they had the next round in san
francisco
and i did not win that was mike berman
who went on to host a show mike and
maddie he was a he was a minor
television celebrity for a while he was
very good
so you're a major television celebrity
sure sure
that in 450
no he's a acquaintance of mine that's
that's
out of the question but uh if you have
four dollars and 50 cents and you're a
minor celebrity
you can go to starbucks
wow and get a coffee okay yeah well now
they're shutting them all down so wait
wait a minute wait a minute rain how
much do you pay for a coffee
is it different than the rest of us and
i go into a starbucks and i open my
mouth and then they the baristas
lovingly pour lattes down my throat
always i always assume that that's what
happened so you're the guy
you know it was always with all the
vaseline
on the lens i wasn't sure it was you
ray and i got here in my hand my newest
delivery from trade coffee it's called
common voice
uh it's got notes of dark cherry and
chocolate and brown sugar it's from
central america a nice little medium
roast and i haven't tried it yet but i
know i'm gonna love it and do you know
why because trade coffee went through
the trouble of asking me these very
interesting questions about what kind of
coffee i like what kind of taste i
gravitate towards how do i like to make
my coffee do i like it you know and do i
want to grind it myself do i have a
coffee machine do i do drip what do i
and then they built this like coffee
profile so every month i get a new bag
of coffee
you know usually a roaster i've never
heard of before i try it and every month
i'm telling you they hit a home run so
folks trade coffee connects customers to
the freshest and best tasting coffee
they've ever made at home by partnering
with the country's best craft roasters
these are independent businesses from
big cities and small towns trade
customers are truly impactful for these
independent roasters because they're
often the largest source of new growth
for them trades coffee team actually
taste tests thousands of coffees to keep
450 different kinds
live and ready to ship every day there's
no one perfect coffee but
there is a perfect coffee for you and
trade's human powered algorithm will
find it trade is offering new
subscribers a total of thirty dollars
off your first order plus free shipping
when you go to drinktrade.com milkshake
that's more than 40 cups of coffee for
free
get started by taking their quiz at
drink trade dot com slash milkshake let
trade find you a coffee you'll love
that's drinktrade.com milkshake for 30
off
after that people wanted me to do steve
martin impressions at events
but it doesn't take long for you to
realize that you're not steve martin in
my case that i was not steve martin
and uh you want to do your own stuff and
so
one thing led to another
but i i met steve martin and he was very
gracious to me he was very nice he
didn't need to be he was very nice
yeah uh anyway
uh you know as i said you know the story
he said sort of
we got through it it was cool so just
getting back to the show for a second
here um we talked about you know the
show takes us through different ways in
which
uh the world could end and each one i i
like that each one each episode not
almost live listeners this is the new
show the end is yes
almost live was a comedy show in which
every episode was about the world coming
to an end no uh
no the end of the story
uh well i also like the fact that you
know each one of these episodes ends
with some kind of you know a note of
hope a note of positivity the second
half hour is all about the optimistic
view of the future through science
science exactly
but
i'm curious you know doing this the the
show these uh was it six episodes
yeah six
well i would you know why they're six
why
i don't know either yeah six is just one
of those numbers
so it's a it's a product of two prime
numbers which may that's probably one
that's probably why oh yeah that's
probably what they were thinking
i'm just curious which episode
scared you
the most
and don't say climate change let's let's
let's put climate change aside but like
which are the episodes we're going to
get into that yeah well they're all
scary
um
if the world runs out of food
because the heartland of north america
is buried
that would be a drag
if the world runs out of food because
the heartland runs out of water
that would be a drag
if there are two
back-to-back or 12-hour apart solar
flares that turns off all the
electricity in the world in a day
that would also be bad
uh so all of them basically yeah all of
them so all these different scenarios
that you've got going um and we're gonna
get to climate in a little bit but
which is which is the most realistic
like which which is the most i mean
climate
the effects of climate change is
non-negotiable it's a non-starter it's
already happening it's going to increase
they're going to get worse putting that
aside which of the other disaster
scenarios is really the most realistic
what what do we what should we actually
get prepared for a comet impact
okay
is very reasonable very low probability
very high consequence
in very large solar flare so-called
coronal mass ejections
very likely i mean any minute so there
was a thing no preparation for that one
yes there is prep oh there is make me
come over there heck yes
so
i don't want to give it away well first
first tell us what what what happens
with the solar flare so this is where
the sun
which is an ordinary star i mean it's i
won't say it's unremarkable it's our sun
but there's nothing especially special
about it
in 1859
there were two there was the carrington
event where these solar flares these
coronal mass ejections
caused
fires
in telegraph offices and destroyed
telegraph systems back when there were
very few wires strung above the ground
the earth at the earth's magnetic field
becomes this antenna
for this uh energy these particles and
magnetic zap coming from the sun
and if you had a big one or two of those
you would turn off all the electricity
in the world so what you want to do
is get the electrical grid
robust enough
that it can handle this you want to plan
for it
and the example of not planning for
stuff that happens is the texas
electrical grid
when it the whole place went down
just because it got pretty cold it
didn't get extraordinarily cold just a
little cold well it got texas cold you
know i'm i used to work in west texas
as a young engineer i worked for a
seattle company that had an oil field
product
that was derivative of oil slick
skimming boats
and it gets very cold in texas in the
winter nothing between you and the north
pole but a barbed wire fence
and even that's blown down
okay
and so uh it got a little bit cold in
texas pretty quickly and it ruined
everything i mean
to the point where a u.s senator left
town it got so cold
so
no it did and so you don't want that to
happen on a national or international or
global scale
and so to prevent that
we have to acknowledge that it's
possible that's the first half of the
show and then the second half is all the
cool little things we do to prevent it
from being catastrophic that's a good
one
you know you at the start of this
interview you mentioned how
you know disaster movies are all the
rage whenever things are going poor yeah
that's not my idea that's just some
human nature yeah it's totally and you
know but it is your idea to take
advantage of that with a
with a more scientific unscripted series
about disasters but here's the here's
the thing is that
the trouble with these a lot of these
disaster scenarios is that they are
often sudden you know but that's not
really what we're facing right now i
mean minus you know the comet and the
solar flare which could just happen
it feels like more likely we're in this
kind of uh sort of uh in a frog and
boiling water situation oh man that's
the problem yeah people talk about
climate change is the slow motion nature
of it well even with even more troubles
you know rayna and i were talking about
this earlier that like if you had told
us
in 2020
that
a pandemic was coming and a million
americans were gonna die we would have
lost our [ __ ]
like if you had said that and a million
americans died and were kind of like
well you know i do i have to wear a mask
on a plane though really
so well if you're talking about it
scientifically they wouldn't let us do a
pandemic episode oh yeah i bet and the
other two really they wouldn't let us
let's say do some other ones first yeah
let's do that the other one first they
wouldn't um they discouraged us from
pursuing was
totalitarianism oh yeah yes yeah too
close to home
right now those are both pretty close to
home yeah so season two
i guess great question that would be
great i guess my question is bill
will we even know
that the end is nigh
as it's happening or will we just be
going to starbucks and well if it's a
comet impact we'll know if
you know but um the thing about a comet
in that one example
is it's 20 years out
you know if you can find the thing 30
years before it's going to hit the earth
then you can do something about it
when you don't figure it out for if it's
only got a year
if you only have a year of warning i
mean
then it gets a lot more complicated but
people have ideas for it
turn it up turn them watch the show turn
it up loud
well the the frog in the boiling water
analogy is used so often i remember
hearing that when i was five years old
about humanity being a frog in boiling
water and it really just scaring the
the piss out of me my point is this
going back to climate change so this is
your first episode although you don't
mention climate change
it's the most analogous to the frog in
boiling water uh situation and climate
change is something that i'm passionate
about i'm on the board of a non-profit
that deals with climate change i have
participated in many events i try and
use my social media to educate people
about it and it's it's so tricky bill i
know you you know this
backwards and forwards inside and out
far better than i do you know the
science of it you know the politics of
it
but it seems to me that in order to
quote unquote combat climate change now
and to um to kind of
set our carbon output at such a level
where
the results will not be cataclysmic is
going to be super hard and super
expensive it's going to take shutting
down coal plants finding alternative
energies renew reusable energies
renewable energies it's going to be
taxing beef
and taxing soy stopping the
the bulldozing of
of of forests it's going to be you know
it's going to take regulation of air
conditioning and
can't be regulations
regulation i know government regulation
of construction projects and how
concrete is made um it goes it goes on
and on and on and people talk about the
costs of this well we can't do it it
will hurt the economy so bad we can't do
it and yet you fools don't you see that
in 50 or 100 years the economy will be
brought staggeringly to its knees if we
don't
undertake these extremely draconian and
painful measures now but we're talking
about decades we're talking about a
hundred years and it's so hard for
people to wrap their silly little minds
about it i know you have thought about
this in great detail
if this were a game show
could you express this sentiment in the
form of a question
are we screwed
uh so the you guys it's a question of
degree and that i guess is a pun
it's degrees of temperature but it's
also how many of the eight going on nine
billion people are going to be in
trouble and how many are going to get
through
with relative comfort relatively
comfortable lifestyle and that depends
as you point out on all the decisions we
make right now
so
i hearken continually
to my beloved parents
both of whom were
veterans of world war ii
my
dad was a prisoner of war captured from
this tiny island in the pacific ocean
called wake island he spent four years
as a prisoner of war
wow after fighting back against the
japanese navy for a while and then my
mom was the one of the code girl she was
recruited to work on the
the enigma code and then later in the
war apparently she worked on the
japanese codes
jn codes
and my point is simply that everybody
at that time everybody in
the allied societies u.s britain friend
everybody was intent on winning the war
everybody and in five years they did
so if
if we can get a substantial fraction of
the world's population intent on
addressing climate change we will
and so uh that is uh our mission with
this show with the first episode of the
show
is
let's take steps to prevent this come on
people let's get her done and you know
and i i absolutely appreciate that and
you know it's not like i disagree you
know that we need to take steps uh to
address it um i was reading this uh
quote here by mit professor kieran setia
who says that there is a genuine
possibility that within the coming
century we will hit temperatures that
are deeply incompatible with the
continued existence of human life
yeah so it means everybody a lot of
people are going to die yes a lot of
people are going to die but here's the
thing bill is that
i have a hard time
actually believing that we are going to
do anything about it i mean i i've heard
you suggest that you know while
certainly we can do things in our own
personal lives individually and i gotta
tell you
i gotta disabuse you of that
this idea that
if we all just do this if we all carpool
if we all recycle our bottles
if we all recycle and everything will be
okay well okay well there you go that's
even worse than i was gonna say no he's
gonna give it much bleaker ideas man we
need huge ideas but yeah this is what
this is what reza is saying i see that's
go ahead
the thing
let's be optimistic we need
better electricity production this would
be distributed electricity production
with in the two examples solar and wind
we need uh base load production which is
probably i won't be shocked
some form of nuclear power that gets
figured out on a very small scale
compared to what has been done in the
past
then we need energy storage batteries
then we need better transmission lines
somebody's going to make money during
all this
contractors will be hired
to erect wind turbines and build
transmission lines somebody's going to
invent a better battery and he or she is
going to get rich
and so
uh we can do this everybody the hand
ringing it's all over is crazy making
and i hearken again
to what the
united states especially is done
to win world war ii to put people on the
moon
to invent the internet
to feed now we're feeding almost nine
billion people
on less land or eight billion people on
less land than we fed one and a half
billion people in my grandparents time
so
the hand ringing i understand it the
longest journey maybe the first thing
about digging a hole is to stop digging
but let's we can do this people come on
that's why we're making the show
because we can do this i hear everything
that you're saying and i don't
necessarily even disagree with it and i
really
appreciate the the optimism that you
that you bring to it it's hard you're
not optimistic you're not going to get
anything done i i hear that you think
you're going to lose the game you will
freaking lose again right but but we are
what we are relying on
is that
there's some 16 year old kid out there
who's about to invent some incredible
carbon capturing technology and that may
very well may happen that's how that's
how human progress has has worked you
know there might be somebody out there
who's going to figure out some way to um
you know deal with uh the the the
problems that that arise with with food
production uh et cetera et cetera what i
think is very hard and i wouldn't even
call this skeptical or pessimistic i
would call it uh profoundly realistic
it's very hard to actually say that the
people who are responsible politicians
business leaders for
forcing upon
american the american public the change
is necessary to actually reverse uh the
damage that we're doing to the climate
it's almost impossible to imagine that
actually happening yes is it possible to
imagine that the new technology a new
invention will will arise that will
change everything absolutely is it
possible to actually think that our
politicians our leaders are going to do
what is necessary to actually get us out
of this emergency hell's no
hell's no bill
so i say all the time when people ask me
what can i do about climate change a
person i say vote
if you're too young to vote make sure
the grown-ups in your life vote and when
they vote take the environment into
account
so i
i hearken to this idea you know the
united states is
this became this model
democracy for the world where they had
this idea we're gonna have a government
without a king
really no king we're gonna have a queen
no queen
no what about dukes and earls no none of
them
wow how's that gonna work anyway that's
a cool idea the place has almost gone
out of business
a few times
you know the war of 1812 that was
that was a skirmish maybe
civil war the u.s almost went out of
business uh world war ii
the us could have gone out of business
and right now the u.s could go out of
business but i think
i believe
we will not go out of business thanks to
the diligence of
the systems that are rather the people
that are operating the levers of the
systems that are in place
so
everybody please vote with the
environment in mind
please vote with the peaceful trans
transition of power in mind
so that we can solve these problems and
change the world
which all begins of course
with watching the end is nine
yeah that's that's where it all begins
it begins with the television show
and a podcast and a correlating
uh podcast august 25th very good well
said the you know i was in doing some
research about you and our researchers
doing some research about you we see
that in 2016
you dismissed philosophy is useless and
misguided when someone challenged you on
it you said that you had reevaluated
your position and you started
incorporating this into your work and
your you've you and i love this i love
that i don't know if this story is
correct but i wanted to ask you about it
and you said ah now i'm all about the
philosophy bring it on in your master
class you talked about science as a
philosophy so here we're posed with
humanity's greatest existential question
of all time which is climate change and
the science that requisite science to
combat said climate change and there is
a underlying philosophy of all
underneath all of that which is in my
mind is kind of like a star trek
philosophy which is
you know um the greatest good for the
greatest people brought upon
brought there by science
but in what ways do you see science
motivating new philosophical questions
and the philosophy of science tied to
this existential threat of climate
change so
uh
let's just
add this that in when the u.s
constitution was written and the bill of
rights and
so on the term scientist
was not in the vocabulary
was not in english the word science
was extent
in fact if you go to article 1 section 8
clause 8 of the us constitution it
refers to one of the jobs of congress is
to promote the progress of science and
useful arts
but people who were scientists at that
time were called natural philosophers
and so if you say if one says
summarizing philosophy
as a system or means to seek
truth or that which is true
then natural philosophers are trying to
learn the truth of nature or that
what the facts of nature and that to me
is inspirational and cool and uh
and
along that line built in to philosophy
is
when you get more evidence you change
your mind or you modify your
point of view or how you feel about the
world or what you accept to be true
and so uh
i'm all about philosophy now i think
it's the greatest thing and i must have
been saying it
as i look back
being dismissive of certain pursuits
that
at that time didn't seem to be practical
but apparently
the most
employable
the most employable liberal arts
degree is in philosophy apparently
philosophy majors are very flexible you
give them a job they find a job to do
they'll figure out how to solve problems
and do it that's kind of cool well i
love what you said about a natural
philosopher and like a science a
scientist being a natural philosopher
well that was that was the term of art
if you talk to benjamin franklin or
somebody he would consider himself a
natural philosopher
yeah i hadn't i hadn't thought about
that but seeking truth you know trying
to think your way to truth
and a problem we have right now is that
ideas that are not fact based
are provably false
are finding purchase or
getting
support
in our society and this is you know what
everybody calls misinformation
and uh it's you know when the internet
was invented or or came to be
uh organically through everybody running
around with computers communicating with
each other
everybody thought this would be great
we'll democratize information i remember
those days everyone will be able to
share ideas and the best ideas will rise
to the top and it's all going to be
great but that's not what happened
but i think the
through the process of science this this
system will correct itself we will
correct the system
you know
the whole idea everybody the whole idea
in science or let's say natural
philosophy seeking the truth about
nature
the premise of the bit
that's a comedy term the premise of the
bit is that the universe or the cosmos
or reality or nature is knowable
that you can't that's the idea that you
can figure it out
and so far
science general science writ large
scientists
at large have not come up against
something that is unknowable
they've come up against more mysteries
but nobody has reached the ending oh you
can't know it no let it go even i'm even
talking about i don't want to get in a
fist fight about probabilistic nature of
quantum mechanics
even that i was just about to figure it
is figure out
to the point where we can have these
computers with field effect transistors
and relying on quantum tunneling and all
that we can get pretty close and the
premise is
that we can
we can know it that what we don't know
doesn't mean we're going to stop what we
don't know means we want to reach
farther and deeper and learn more about
nature that's
the truth seeking in nature that's
natural philosophy that
is science
so uh bill putting aside your uh
infectious optimism
and your faith in the ability of science
to to solve uh problems if you were a
betting man okay if this if we're in las
vegas and you are a betting man
how does the world end
how does the human world end yep
i think humans
you know it's been argued in fact the
guy at the university of washington
argues that the humans are extinction
proof
so
really
yeah because there's so many of us and
we're such
huge brains compared to our body and
we're always coming up with crap
that somebody's going to make it through
the question is how
a question that i ask myself continually
is how many of us are going to make it
through with a pretty nice quality of
life
and uh i think
in about 70 years
in other words people talk about 50
years but you talk about between now and
a century from now things the human
population will have naturally started
to decrease
and the human influence the inadvertent
human influence on the environment will
be less
and in that meantime people will be
taking steps as stewards of earth
to make life a little better for a lot
of people but i think the worst is yet
ahead and the best is yet ahead after
that
i love that bill um
that is i love i love that optimism that
you bring to this and that counters
reza's natural pessimism
here's another thing that um
barry obama he was a government employee
for a while i remember president obama
that was that was his yeah he said
famously if you couldn't pick
where
you would be born on earth
but you could pick when
some magical science fiction thing
you'd pick now
as messed up as things seem to be things
are actually messed up
less messed up
for fewer of us than ever in human
history you know human life expectancy
used to be
less than 40 years
for fewer than 40 years
well now you know people live to be 80
and you can say well life expectancy is
going down in the united states the
world's most technically advanced okay
be that as it may
if you couldn't pick where but you can
pick when
this would be the time things suck less
for fewer people than ever in history of
by fraction
so we can do this people let's get her
done
let's go
the world sucks less with you in it bill
nye the science guy
and with your new tv show
and the way that you
uh make science accessible for
hundreds of millions over the years and
got your start as a steve martin
impersonator on in seattle
uh
political engineer you know i worked on
747. yeah but the steve martin stuff
yeah yeah okay all that science stuff is
great but the comedy the comedy was so
good the speed walker character that you
played i remember
um
thanks for being on the show
speaking
three people we would talk to citizen
officer and punk
i didn't talk to anybody
so anyway you guys thanks for having me
on it's been big fun
let's change the world all right let's
do it the end is turn it up loud
will do thanks bill
well okay uh that was interesting and
instructive and funny and humorous and
and uh yes somewhat uh
somewhat uh encouraging i guess did it
make me feel any better
oh
you horrible little pessimist yes it
made me feel better you know what you
know how this was inspiring to me tell
me is
well
i don't know if you know this but bill
nye has been at the leading edge of the
debate on climate from the get-go he's
the one who's been on like fox news
laura ingram like he's been on the
battle lines uh with the anti-science
crowd and they're like well you're not a
phd oh yeah and you're not a
climatologist and you know but they are
um
and
but here's the thing like
no one should be more pessimistic
than bill nye because he has been
fighting this so hard and the supreme
court recently ruled that the epa does
not have jurisdiction over clean air in
our country
um it's absolutely astonishing and if he
this guy fighting the fight in the
trenches can just be filled with that
kind of can-do optimism and i love going
back to the idea of the marshall plan
world war ii getting to the moon you
know giant
planet-sized missions
um i thought it was really inspiring
because i get really pessimistic too and
the problem with pessimism
is
it makes you complacent it's just easy
to go house [ __ ] this is all a bunch of
[ __ ]
and um and not do anything and that's
the problem with so many uh young people
today so i just
it really inspired me to like you know
what i need to put my pessimism aside
and i gotta try i'm gonna try i'll go to
my deathbed saying you know it'll be on
my tombstone well he tried
i mean look i i agree with all of that
and uh
i i guess
you're right you're right actually
you're right i do feel better okay i
will say i feel i think okay good i feel
like
you were around i feel like three
degrees better i feel three degrees
better uh but i but i do think that what
makes me feel better is i do
i do share his faith
in science
and science's ability
to
you know heed the call
and to and to save us from disaster and
that's why i was saying like
i think i am much i i believe that it's
much more likely
that
it will be some kind of technological or
scientific advance that we have yet to
really think about
um
and i think maybe carbon capture is a
big part of that like you know carbon
capture is just something we're sort of
doing now and it's not you know it but
like
maybe there's a technology out there a
decade away that will allow us to
capture all the carbon and really really
reverse the problems of climate change
but i have to be honest with you and
maybe it's just the last couple of years
in america when someone tells me that
the answer is to vote i lose my [ __ ]
mind do you honestly believe that we are
ever going to see 60 democrats in senate
again and without 60 democrats who gives
a [ __ ] like we could vote all we want to
and nothing's going to happen america is
not built anymore for 60
democrats and so this idea that like
eventually the politicians will come
around i find to be
the
profoundly naive in fact
almost like demonically naive
that said well the proof is the proof is
in the pudding right now because we're
in the one of the largest democratic
majorities we've had in decades and how
does it what is happening right now
biden has just just approved another oil
drilling in an oil line in alaska
you know which besides what that does to
the wilderness the whole idea that we're
even putting any money time or attention
on excavating more oil is ridiculous
and meanwhile one [ __ ] from west
virginia
who is
by far
by matters of degree
the biggest recipient in both houses of
congress
of money from the coal and gas industry
uh is keeping us from passing the most
basic basic
climate change uh you know legislation
so
i just i you know
here's here's what i worry about
i worry
that this kind of
naive optimism
uh
is gonna keep us from doing what maybe
we should be doing which is planning for
the end like really sitting around and
being like hey there is no way we are
going to stop the planet from heating up
three degrees before the end of the
century so what do we do how do we get
ready for that instead of continuing to
say
no no we can do it all we got to do is
vote yeah but that's not going to happen
either because planning for the end
means alternative food sources
it means water desalination plants it
means
you know alternate technologies which
are not profitable business lines by the
way and so no one is going to be sinking
the hundreds of billions of dollars into
that
um anyway yeah so
either way we're screwed i mean this
maybe this is a question for our for our
milk shakers what do you guys think are
we [ __ ] are we doomed everyone uh do
you feel optimistic do you think science
has a path for us to get out of this
mess do you think the politicians
possibly if we just vote for the right
people you know uh bill used the the
example of world war ii uh but that was
something that everyone saw and couldn't
deny right it was like
i'd i'd much prefer a a comet heading
towards us right because at least then
we could all well now i'm thinking about
don't look up and so yeah you're
thinking about the movie don't look
never mind what do you what do you guys
think let us know are you optimistic
pessimistic follow us at
metaphysicalmilkshake on instagram you
can hit us up on our socials you can
write us at metaphysical cast media.com
please uh subscribe to our youtube
channel tell your friends about our show
and we would love to incorporate all of
your questions and comments and
personalities and love
into
a metaphysical milkshake concoction
yummy and don't forget to watch bill
nye's a new series on peacock it is
called the end is nigh and it is truly
an entertaining show regardless of
whether it scares the [ __ ] out of you or
not thank you everybody see you next
week
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samazadeh yazd harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner original music by
jeff tang
[Music]
by the way i love the fact that they all
hang out together like all these
hurricanes
they're all on the same list served you
know
happy hour
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you